the writers in hollywood now you know a
lot of them will have gone to college
for four or five years where they've
been told incessantly the world is
inherently racist and sexist everyone's
awful everyone hates each other it's
just this big hierarchy of people
getting oppressed by everyone else and
so that's going to reflect in their
mindset and it's going to reflect in
what they write and what they try to
rationalize in their stories and that's
why you get what you end up with
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissen
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
novelist youtuber and film critic will
jordan aka the critical drinker welcome
to trigonometry thank you for having me
uh it's such a pleasure to have you've
got a brilliant youtube channel that's
absolutely crushing it we're really
interested to talk to you about what's
happening in the movie world and some of
the ideologies and all of that stuff but
before we do uh tell us who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life to lead you to be
sitting here talking to us uh well i'm
reasonably sure that i'm will jordan
i'm a writer and eventually i became a
youtuber um i guess i got into this
whole thing because i'd always been
interested in storytelling i've been
fascinated by by characters and how you
can just you know you can create these
fictional worlds that people can just
lose themselves and i think there's
something really special and magical
about that um and so it eventually led
me to becoming an author myself and um
you know ropes nine ten books now um so
it became quite a successful thing for
me and um yeah i was really pleased with
that but
you know
several years ago i guess i began to
notice
um a change in the movies that we were
we were seeing in cinemas um they were
gradually losing that that kind of magic
and that ability to lose yourself in the
story um and it was becoming
more and more obvious that they were
trying to inject
the politics the the beliefs the
ideologies of the writers um into the
stories and you were losing then your
your your characters your quality of
your storytelling and particularly when
they were doing it to
um older characters that they were
bringing back you know they were
essentially just bringing back these old
actors these old characters and kind of
breaking them down and humiliating them
um and funnily enough i didn't like that
because i used to be a fan of a lot of
these people
uh and so i decided i need to
just try and i guess add my voice to
that conversation about it and i thought
well i can i can get back into youtube
because i used to do it way back when
just messing around just little little
channel with a few hundred subscribers
so i started that up again and um
started talking about various movies
uh and there was one day when i don't
know what happened i think maybe i had a
beer or two before i recorded it and i
was like my voice is awfully slurred uh
in this video and well you are scottish
mike yeah exactly i mean what can i do
you know it was like it was 9 a.m of
course you're gonna have a drink
um and i just thought you know i'm just
gonna go with this and have this kind of
slurred drunken voice um that's really
sarcastic and
wow that video went out went viral
before i knew it i had
half a million um maybe a million views
on that and i went from a few hundred
subscribers up to five ten twenty thirty
thousand and then it's just
been a roller coaster from there so it's
been kind of fun mate we need to get you
back on the source yeah exactly
slow your
words here we come what is it they say
in vitae veritas you know there's truth
and drinks yeah exactly i'll go with
that yeah but
what we were talking about just there it
rang so true with me because i come from
more of a theater perspective but i've
i've seen the same thing happen with
theater but let's talk about specific
examples what in particular where have
you noticed it and what films what
characters basically anything known by
disney at this point um you know
obviously they took over the whole star
wars brand they took over marvel
um and particularly with star wars you
would see characters like han solo and
luke skywalker these classic heroes from
from 20 30 years ago that we all knew as
kids that were awesome and suddenly
they're getting brought back and they're
they're like deadbeat dads or they're
just grumpy old men living on an island
and just want to die and they've lost
all hope you know it's um
it's a terrible thing to do to these
characters because it's one thing to
kill them off
it's another thing to destroy their
legacy or the very essence of who they
were and i think that's when i really
started to notice it these
heroes that we used to enjoy
are just being um
denigrated and broken down to try and
push the new heroes that they tried to
replace them with which are just
usually cardboard cutouts with no real
personalities that was the frustrating
part for me and we'll look there'll be
people here going hang on a second right
hollywood has always pushed certain
narratives it has always pushed certain
politics the american dream that you can
go and be and do anything that you want
to to be or to do isn't that politics do
you know what i mean i i think there's a
difference there in terms of um one how
pervasive it is in the story because now
it's so obvious and it's usually paired
up with
a lack of writing skill like the writers
are usually stumbling over themselves so
quickly to push this stuff in they
neglect to even bother with a good story
the other aspect like i just described
there is the
the trampling of of what came before and
the
you know
exploiting the work of previous
generations of writers and storytellers
to try and elevate the the stuff that
you're producing now
so i think those two strands combined is
just what makes it so distasteful now
and it's quite a shift because in the
past if you were doing a remake of
something or a sequel to something or a
prequel to something you were kind of
going like this was successful so we'll
do more of that whereas now you're
starting to see like you say where
something that used to be a certain way
is now being presented as something else
and you feel it's kind of affecting the
quality of what's being made very much
so yeah um it's one thing to um
to produce sequels to to previously
successful movies you know hollywood's
been doing that for decades now fair
enough it's another thing to start to
say hey you know you know these guys
that you used to enjoy so much these
stories that you used to appreciate they
were never that good
what we're making now is better but it's
not it's just a lie that you're expected
to buy into and it's patronizing to the
viewer that's the thing that really gets
on my nerves like i was watching i mean
it's slightly different i was watching
miss mazel which i really enjoyed the
first three seasons were great and then
in the fourth season it went weird they
they started preaching almost this kind
of feminist message and you're going
i don't give a [ __ ] just tell me the
story
there's ways to work ideas like that
into the story subtly yeah so that you
you can in almost uh present both sides
of an argument and let the audience make
up their minds with stuff like that and
just show the characters encountering
difficulties um that's one way to do it
but if you just are straight up telling
the audience this is what you must think
this is what you must believe
that's just a hallmark of bad writing
and it's what you see more and more now
it's
it's where you're then removed from the
story you're no longer losing yourself
in a fictional world that you can
believe in all you're seeing is the
beliefs of the writer
that's that's what it becomes and that's
when it's
detrimental and why do you think this is
happening well
uh
i mean there's a broad shift in our
culture i think at the moment um
you know we i guess people talk about
woke politics and and social justice and
stuff how it's become really prevalent
um in the past several years
i think in hollywood in america there
was um there was obviously a broad
general reaction to the election in
2016. that that drove a lot of people
nuts and it was it was essentially a
backlash then amongst the people of
hollywood against that
um so i think all of those things
combined are what's causing this um
this shift in what we see in movies and
storytelling um it's an attempt to make
people
feel and think a certain way yeah look
i'm sure that had a huge impact but it
feels to me and maybe you'll correct me
that actually something has been
changing for longer even than that and
the reason i say this is
like francis and i were talking about
this before we started where
there used to
quite often a movie used to have a
fairly simplistic possibly but a moral
message of some kind or a very uh
aspirational quality to it like if you
think about movies from when i was a kid
whether you think they're good or not
like independence day or whatever it was
all about triumph over some kind of
foreign
hostile invasion people coming together
all over the world it was all about
uniting and working together to succeed
in some way
whereas
more recently even in like stuff that i
think is incredibly well made whether
that's game of thrones or house of cards
or anything like that i started to see
that actually what they were doing now
is showing the opposite and going look
at all the deep
dysfunction in human beings look at all
the terrible ways that people operate
look at the way people cheat and steal
and and and
murder and do all of those horrible
things and it's shown from a kind of
different perspective so instead of
giving you an aspirational picture it
was it became more about going look how
bad everything is well i think that that
ties into the mindset of a lot of uh
the writers in hollywood now you know a
lot of them will have gone to college
for four or five years where they've
been told incessantly the world is
inherently racist and sexist everyone's
awful everyone hates each other it's
just this big hierarchy of people
getting oppressed by everyone else and
so that's going to reflect in their
mindset and it's going to reflect in
what they write and what they try to
rationalize in their stories and that's
why you get what you end up with
and yeah it's
it is so disheartening because like you
say there used to be an aspirational
message to so much of of movie making
you know whether it was
characters like rocky who have to to you
know rise to some big challenge to try
and overcome it whether it's something
like independence day like a big cheesy
blockbuster movie but there's a positive
message there about people putting aside
their differences to to take on a bigger
threat um unashamedly pro-american i
suppose as well
and that's again what you see
now is there's this kind of
nihilism and this kind of uh
almost hatred of their own country you
know america was never that good anyway
and it was all founded on on racism and
slavery and all that stuff um
it just it
engenders this kind of negative mindset
in the audience i think and they come
away unsatisfied by it i don't know if
the writers in their way feel like well
we're making the world a better place
because we're educating people about the
problems of the world but there's a
format for doing that and
if you just focus on that
you end up just leaving your audience
feeling downbeat and unhappy
and i think that's why
you know a movie like top gun maverick
that came out it's a sequel to film from
like the 80s
you know it should never even in in all
um you know in any rational world it
never even should have got made so long
um you know
so many years later
um but there it is and it's and it's a
really good fun movie it's positive it's
upbeat it doesn't try and um
denigrate the past or put down its
previous generation of characters it's
respectful
um and it ends up just being a really
great fun movie and people come out of
that feeling good about themselves
what's so bad about that
you know
it's a lot we're allowed to feel happy
occasionally not anymore yeah but you
know sorry just on this very point
francis like
you mentioned for example slavery right
there's a history of movies about
slavery i remember as a kid
here at school going to see amsterdam
amistad
and that is a movie about a horrible
chapter in human history but it also
shows that people working together and
people uh
advocating for their rights and and
freedom of express all of that stuff can
actually achieve a result it's saying
like we're not doomed as human beings to
the worst elements of our past we're not
doing to our most base instincts we're
not doomed to to be constantly stuck in
this endless eternal battle between
groups actually when we work together we
can get to the point of our common
humanity actually triumphing over all
that tribalism yeah
and now we're just doing the exact
opposite
we're just going here's here's another
movie about how we're all evil yes you
know
uh
not nice yeah i mean i there's nothing i
can add to that like you pretty much
articulate it perfectly it's the
yeah it's the mindset now of making
movies but surely that's gotta that's
gotta be unsustainable you'd think but
they keep doing it i mean my my
rationale has always been uh eventually
the money will run out you know so many
of these movies that they try to do
uh they fail and they end up losing
money for the studio um and you know as
many
ideologically driven people as there are
in hollywood there's even more guys who
are just money men
they just want to make cash and they
don't care what it is that does that but
if they see enough movies that are in
the red
there has to come a point where they say
enough of this crap we've got to stop
this we have to start making movies that
are actually popular that people like
so you just you have to hope that
eventually it's going to filter through
i mean like i say there's there's
occasional films that um that do crop up
like like top gun maverick that um that
have done really well and hopefully they
serve as a little um you know lesson for
people
that it can still work these older style
movies that are
positive upbeat patriotic whatever it
might be
they can be a massive success if they're
done right um we just have to hope that
it will happen eventually
you know these are always some points
because i remember going to watch 12
years a slave and i remember saying to
my ex-girlfriend as i walked out i said
i think the only way you can enjoy that
film is if you are actually racist
[Laughter]
that's the only way because
apart from that it's just an hour and a
half of some of the most horrific
violence against black people and you go
this is this is put this is obviously
accurate all of these things but you go
this
it's just awful it doesn't leave you
with any any sense
of you know
of anything apart from just deep horror
yeah i mean obviously different movies
are designed to do differently there's
nothing wrong with that i mean
it's the same right you watch it to get
a picture of what happened yeah you know
you're not walking out they're looking
for a feel-good moment yeah exactly you
can you know you can watch schindler's
list you're probably not going to have a
blast watching that movie but it depends
on your political opinion yeah but it's
an important movie yeah it's cool and
it's a it's obviously a deeply moving
and poignant film um but not necessarily
uh an enjoyable film yeah but you know
so i think different films can do that
but i think the problems come in when
you're ostensibly trying to make some
some
blockbuster you know fun upbeat movie
and then you start working in this other
stuff like oh by the way do you know
that like loads of people in america are
racist or you know whatever it might be
it's just it often comes across as just
weird
moments of you're trying to make
something into something that's not
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview did you know that you can ask
guests like the critical drinker your
questions that's right when you join our
local community not only will you know
who we're about to interview you have
the opportunity to ask them your
questions it's not just a critical
drinker either you have the chance to
ask jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norco
simon evans larry elder david bedeal
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein
inaudible david nutt jimmy dore gad sad
blair white melissa chen trevor phillips
i am hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford i
see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge
metaphorically speaking not just because
they're american our locals gives you
access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
means and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well on the higher
tiers you get monthly supporter calls
and the opportunity to have a meal or a
call with us click the link below or go
to trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
the the interesting thing as well is
that they make these racist characters
so clunky yeah where they do you just go
if you're a racist you wouldn't be
racist
at the top of your voice in a public
place where everyone can hear
you know it's just completely terrible
writing yeah and it's just it's
clumsiness on the part of the writers um
whether they don't have the experience
um whether they uh are just like i say
falling over themselves to get that
point across and they don't care how
clumsily they do it
maybe that's how it is but uh yeah
there would in the past i think there
would be more of a
nuance to these characters you know you
might show them
having uh positive qualities but also
there's this darker side to them that
comes across sometimes and it's it'd be
an interesting way of saying well this
is this is how it manifests in people
sometimes
they might not consciously be aware of
it they might not always be a big
cartoonish
um you know
racist who's just yelling at his lungs
but
it comes across subtly
but that can be the the difference in a
character but yeah i just don't think
writers these days have got that kind of
subtlety to them do you think part of
the problem as well is
what happened with weinstein was
obviously horrific and awful but then
hollywood was almost forced to yeah say
look this is all horrific and awful and
we're going to produce these films that
have an element of social justice to
show that we have changed oh very much
so yeah they were they were terrified of
that because
let's be honest a lot of them were
implicated in it as being complicit you
know so many of these stars that were
you know
preaching about how how appalled they
were by him it's like there's there's
hundreds of pictures of them like nick
standing next to him getting their
pictures taken uh praising him to the
the hill and and
the thing is they all knew as well it's
not like they just randomly took
pictures yeah and then there's all these
rumors that come out like this person
knew that person knew but it was it
would have ended their career if they
were to speak out and so yeah it's
uh like you say the backlash to that um
prompted this huge uh panic amongst them
and it's like yeah we have to prove how
virtuous we are um and suddenly that's
why you get uh you know diversity quotas
to to even be nominated for an oscar
really yeah you to even be considered
for an oscar now you have to have you
know x number of women
in front of or behind the camera x
number of of uh ethnic minorities x
number of lgbt people um in hollywood i
would have certainly
they're the majority aren't they well
you never know but um again i'm not a
big fan of this idea that um the the
composition of your movie in terms of
the people working on it should
determine whether or not it's good
what should speak for itself is the end
product um and so when you start getting
into that mindset of um you know a movie
can only be considered worthy if it's
got x number of of different boxes
ticked in terms of the people working on
it
you're not necessarily going to get the
best people
you're just you're taking boxes like i
say and that's just that's a really bad
way of working it's like they're trying
to
really artificially tackle a problem
that should be much more um organically
changed you know the whole culture i
guess of hollywood needs to shift
to to just let more people in to work on
these films and give them a chance to
succeed on their own merits not force
them into positions they might not be
ready for
it's it's an interesting point and i i
think it comes back to what you said
earlier which is
we've kind of got to a position where
like we all think that our job is to
educate other people and and what what
they mean by that is to force them to
think in a different way yeah right and
there's there's an extraordinary level
of arrogance that's implied within that
which is you have the knowledge
that other people must accept as fact
and act accordingly and i think that's
kind of where the diversity quota stuff
comes from because it's like there's a
right way to think and it must be
enforced it can't just be introduced
but
do you think this is going to change
over time we talked about top gunman but
like i know the daily wire starting now
my big fear with the daily wire movies
was like they're going to make like
there's a left-wing hollywood and
they're going to make a right-wing
hollywood and then we've just got two
extraordinarily politicized
movie-making
things and the people who actually just
want to watch a good movie
aren't going to do that but from what
i've been hearing actually the daily
wires making things that are
the non-documentary stuff that's just a
good movie or that's their trump that's
what they're trying to do so do you
think the pushback's already started or
do you think we're some way off i think
it has started yeah and um you know
companies like the daily wire it's good
that they're doing what they're doing
they are um
i don't know if they're really going to
become a legitimate rival to hollywood
because they're ultimately just one
company they can only produce so many
films and they've only got so much of a
budget
um yeah i've seen one two of the things
that they've produced um that the run
hide fight was one that i watched which
was which was alright you know it wasn't
an amazing movie but it's kind of a step
in the right direction um
and yeah i
i had hoped that um what we would see is
just more of a realization within
hollywood themselves of
um we can't keep sustaining this we
can't keep bankrolling this kind of
lunacy
and they would gradually shift to more
towards the center ground and
there was signs of it for a while like i
know that the guy who took over um
running disney um bob chapek
uh he he's very much just a money man he
doesn't care about ideology and he even
made that his mission statement he said
we're
disney's now a for-profit company we're
not here to push ideology and we're not
here to get involved in politics and
when he tried to do that there was a
massive backlash against him basically
saying well you must be racist then or
or whatever
and staff were walking out so i don't
know how successful that's ultimately
going to be but um
i guess that it's it's indicative of a
bit of a shift where people are
realizing that uh
what we've been trying to do over the
past five or ten years uh it's slowly
alienating people you know look at the
oscars
that used to be a huge event people are
tuning to watch that now it's like their
ratings are like a third of what they
once were the only thing that got people
talking about this year was will smith
now they literally have to beat each
other together
i said this i made a video about this i
bet you people are going to start
starting fights at the oscars now just
to try and get headlines
you know but
i do find it worrying as someone who
loves film and someone who loves cinema
just look at movie stars
really how many great or new movie stars
have been produced recently
they haven't
you're relying on tom cruise who is a
brilliant movie star one of the greatest
of all time but how old is tom cruise
now he's 59 yeah can you keep relying on
him to do all these new films and get
people into the cinema yeah that age of
the movie star has ended and i've talked
about this on my channel
what you have now is people who get
interested in characters
you know oh there's a new batman movie
some some other douche is going to be
playing batman now or there's a new
superman film or whatever it is you know
they're interested in the the character
rather than the actor playing them now
um and so
what you
what you're losing is that
kind of magic of stardom which just
doesn't exist anymore um there was there
used to be a time when oh [ __ ] there's a
new tom cruise movie of course we you
know we need to go see that because i'm
sure it'll be good
um you know he's like really the last
one there's nobody
is going to get totally fired up that uh
there's a new chris pratt film
um or there's a new dwayne johnson film
like those are just you know
those guys have their their
their careers obviously and they make a
lot of money but like they're not
stars in the same sense that you used to
get 20 30 years ago
and why is that well um probably because
the studios have become so powerful that
uh it's more of an assembly line
of movies than it is you know actual
projects that people are passionate
about
um it's probably going to become like
that with directors as well you used to
have guys like steven spielberg who
would just
you know they could pick and choose the
projects they want you to do they could
get things commissioned but on the
strength of their name because they were
so
powerful within hollywood uh now you've
just got guest directors they get
brought in to do things and um
particularly within these big big budget
marvel movies they don't even really
direct their own movies they are brought
in to do scenes like this where people
are sitting in a room talking to each
other then when it comes to the action
scenes or the cgi someone else does that
they do all that and that's about 90 of
the movie so
now you've got directors who are just
like the actors now they are just
gigging they are happy to get the work
that they can um but they are not big
names anymore that people are excited
about
that's the difference and it's it's
worrying when you look at the industry
when you look at
a lot of the films that make the money
are marvel films and look i quite enjoy
a marvel film but it just shows that
there's a complete dearth of ideas out
there
where the only way to get people to go
and watch a movie is to have spider-man
or all the rest of them what they they
talked about and it was very telling it
was like one of those disney internal
memos was um the franchise ecosystem and
i thought that was just the perfect word
to describe what they do now because
you get a new movie or a new tv show
by any by disney whether it's star wars
or marvel whatever
that will have an old character in it
but it will usually have a couple of new
characters and then they get their own
spin-off movie or spin-off tv show and
then that will in turn create more
spin-offs and it's just this ever
expanding tree of of more stuff
um and
yeah one of my one of my other
content creators we were on a stream a
week or two ago and he showed me all of
the upcoming projects for marvel and
disney over the next 12 months
and i just hung my head and just
i died a little bit inside because
there's so much it's so overwhelming now
and that's all it is it's just um
it's all just about producing more
content
um whether it's movies whether it's tv
shows they're obviously now getting into
the realms of streaming services where
you just need that constant pipeline of
new content
so that people can binge it and what
about the british film industry how is
it is it significantly different or are
we making all the same mistakes here i
don't think we're quite the same as uh
as the americans because
we don't quite have that that streaming
focus that they do and we don't have
these mega huge
companies running things that you know
in the same way that they do so
um britain i think is more
restrained when it comes to that kind of
thing
um but then how many
how many big movies are we producing now
i mean we've got the bond films they
come out once every like five years or
so at this point um i mean bond will be
a woman before long yeah
so
i am baffled by what they're gonna do
with bond now you know they blew him up
at the end of the last movie and then
they end with this little james bond
will return like how
you know
in what form as a ghost
he's got a new identity yeah it'll just
be like reassembled from all those bits
but
the other worrying thing as well is that
the independent cinema
back in the 90s when i really got into
you know into movies you know you had
all these independent houses and okay
they were then bought by companies
people like miramax
they could creating brilliant
independent movies
that doesn't seem to be a thing anymore
like these new
rebel voices like the tarantinos etc it
doesn't exist no i mean my hope was
going to be when we had the lockdowns
the pandemic and everything um and you
know there was no revenue coming in for
for movies and
my assumption was okay the era of the
the mega blockbuster might be over for
now you know studios are just not going
to be able to put two 300 million
dollars into each movie because there's
not necessarily going to be the return
on it people are wary about going to the
cinemas
and so what you might see is that middle
ground that you used to have of movies
on a budget i don't know 50 60 million
relatively small in in hollywood terms
but big enough that they can still look
good they can still have big set pieces
whatever they want to do um
and they can afford to then be a little
bit
more uh
daring they can take more risks with
them they can do you know they could
take a chance on a new director who's
got some crazy idea because they're not
sinking that huge amount of money into
it um but it doesn't seem to have
happened we seem to have gotten right
back to business as usual you know and
you look at the movies coming out this
year you've got what the new jurassic
park movie i mean that was apparently
diabolical yeah i can't wait to see that
i'm so pleased to be there here in
london because i don't have to see it
for a couple of days
but yeah i mean like they they're huge
budgets again back to what we were doing
before and what about taking cinema
cinemas especially post covered like i
used to love going to the cinema and it
used to be a real treat for me when you
sit down you know everything goes dark
and you're just there just to watch a
film it was but i haven't returned to
the cinema i think it's just simply that
i got out of the habit of doing that
what how have the cinema has been
affected
i mean i don't i can't speak for each of
them but um i know when i've gone to see
um
movies this year they're not as busy as
they were back
in 2019 for example or 2018 should i say
um and
whether it is that um
people are just watching at home now
whether they have gotten out of that
habit like you have um they're just
streaming it
or whether some people are still wary
about going back to things like that
just for health reasons i don't know but
um
you know the money that seems to be
coming in from films um
still suggests that people are going
they are making money so maybe they're
yeah maybe i've just been unlucky with
the screenings that i've gone to um but
i do think there'll be a proportion of
people that won't go back
at least not like they did before
yeah there's always going to be that
proportion which is a real shame because
there's something
beautifully communal about going to the
cinema
i love it um
and i love the lack of distractions
because you'll know yourself if you're
watching a film at home you've got your
phone there you've got other people in
the house maybe you may be getting
things delivered or the postman comes
around or whatever there's a million
distractions for you and so
you're you're never quite engaged with
the film you're watching in the way you
are in the cinema like you say
the lights go down the phones go off
and people can just
lose themselves in the movie for a
couple of hours and yeah there's there's
a great um
feeling there where
if something funny happens everyone's
laughing along with it you know
something shocking happens you hear a
little gasp or whatever it's it's cool
it's it's a fun
um way of experiencing it it's a bit
like the theater i suppose this is our
modern version of it yeah well i i think
i'm not making this up i remember
reading something about how even if if
you watch a movie you didn't
particularly like
just the the two hours or three hours in
the dark room watching one thing with
other people it creates what they call
an afterglow like that that feeling when
you first walk out of the cinema yeah of
like having been in a different world
which is one of the reasons you know
where we started this conversation where
you're constantly being dragged out of
that other world by like oh here's a bit
of social justice for you you know
do you feel bad about yourself yes yeah
yeah uh look at this girl boss doing
this or that or whatever um but i was
gonna if i'm in france you mentioned
tarantino
and i was thinking
you know i
i think taran tuna can be gratuitous
sometimes i mean that is his this is his
trademark but i also wouldn't want to
live in a world where tarantino hadn't
made many of the films that he ended up
making
but there is no [ __ ] way in in the
world that he'd be able to
a new tarantino
would ever get a shot now would they no
i think the environment's changed um
movies are just so much safer now
they're so much more corporatized um
for the reasons i've already described
you know one they're
they're usually run by much bigger
companies that
they have to protect their image their
bottom line all that sort of thing and
they've usually sunk so much money into
it that they have to play it safe you
know most of the time they have to play
to it to general audiences now whereas
tarantino's movies obviously you're not
gonna want your your kids going to watch
that you know but they're fantastic
films and so yeah he was very much a
product of his time and it feels like
that time has passed and there's not a
way to bring up guys like him anymore um
there's
you know there's a few directors who've
got a distinct visual style like one of
the ones i talked about recently was the
northman um great movie
and it was the same guy who did the
lighthouse and the names totally escaped
me because i'm sitting here with you
guys right now but um
he's a really good director and he's got
that unique visual style where it's a
little bit um
abstract and it's a little bit arthousy
but it can be tied into that that big
budget
movie um style as well so um guys like
him are really interesting but yeah
they're few and far between now there's
just not people like that getting
created like really um different
interesting creative directors not in
not in mainstream movies at least and
it's also counterproductive as well
because take the example of a film like
dirty dancing
which was made on a shoestring which had
unknowns which told a story about you
know a girl meets boy and it was in the
cat skills i think in the 40s and on
paper you go well how is it this isn't
going to make money
but it's one of the highest grossing
movies of all times and probably one of
the most profitable as well yeah just a
unique combination of
really good actors you know when you've
got patrick swayze at peak patrick's
swayziness you know uh a great sort of
80s soundtrack
um
and
yeah just
one of those like lightning and a bottle
things were it just everything somehow
worked with it i think there was a lot
of tension on set but then it it showed
in how they interacted with each other
and it just uh yeah a film like that was
just one of those happy coincidences
where it just everything happened to
work um
yeah i
i suppose even
you know a lot of the people who worked
on it at the time wouldn't have
predicted that it was going to be this
mega hit they just wouldn't have known
but um yeah sometimes films get lucky
like that
hey constantin do you like shopping no
in russia you skin bear with your bare
hands and wear it obviously this is for
men only women and small children are
allowed to use knife where did you get
your blazer from it's made out of bear
babushka created it for me using nothing
but her own bare hands no pun intended i
wondered what the smell was but for
those of you who do want an easy no
hassle solution to the grind of going
shopping then stitch fix is for you
stitch fix is a service for both men and
women and makes shopping for clothes
easy to get started go to stitchfix dot
co dot uk forward slash trigger to set
up your profile they'll deliver clothes
chosen just for you in your taste size
and budget and by taste they mean
something that will look good instead of
showing the world you're having a
mid-life crisis like me the items you
buy arrive at your door a few days later
you try everything on at home decide
what to keep and then send anything else
back it's so easy you just pay 10 pounds
each time you order which is credited
towards the items you keep and you'll
get 20 off when you keep all five items
there's no subscription plus shipping
returns and exchanges are easy and free
stitch fix does the hard work for you
making shopping for clubs easy and
hassle free get started today at
stitchfix dot co dot uk forward slash
trigger and get 20 percent off when you
keep all five items can you order fresh
siberian bear skin from stitch fix uh
possibly go to stitch fix dot co dot uk
forward slash trigger to find out
and we'll look we've we've been talking
for about an hour now 40 minutes or
whatever it is and we've we've been a
little bit negative just a little bit
just a little bit very unlikely yeah
exactly
yeah are there any you know green shoots
so is there any hope out there is is it
maybe could the new top gun movie maybe
could that spark something i think so
yeah um
i when a movie makes i mean it must be
getting close to 800 million now 800 mil
yeah the last time i checked it was like
770 million worldwide um so it'll reach
800 probably 900s it'd be cool if it
reached a billion but it's probably
going to get pushed out by other
blockbusters this summer but
when a film like that does that well
people take notice and i think they
definitely take notice of when films
fail in in a high profile way and so
yeah i guess we just have to hope that
we see more of this
and with my channel with with the
reviews that i do if i spot movies
nowadays that are genuinely good and
enjoyable hell i'll promote them as much
as i can you know i'll recommend them to
people
so what have been some of obviously
people should go and check out your
channel but for anyone watching this
what have been some of the movies that
you've actually thought have managed to
pierce this sort of politicized social
justice bubble well that was one the
northmen was another one i don't know if
that made a massive amount of money but
it was one that i very much enjoyed um
everything everywhere all at once was a
was a great movie um just
again it was a story about um i think
chinese immigrants and and an older
woman getting to see how her life might
have played out if it should take in
different paths and so on but it was
funny and inventive and just a great
all-round movie
um
the what's the other one that spider-man
movie the most recent one no way home uh
we were all blown away by it because it
had no real politics in it it had no um
social justice staff it you didn't have
a female character that was magically
better than everyone else anything like
that what they did was they took
um
all these older actors who played the
same character brought them all together
into a nice
compelling story let everyone have their
their moment on screen and they were
pretty respectful to previous um
generations of actors that played the
role um and it just all came together
really nice so you know things like that
we were really surprised like who knew
they could make a comic book movie that
was still enjoyable you know
there you go will it's been an absolute
pleasure to have you on we're going to
do a couple of questions for our locals
uh but before we do that we always
finish our interviews with the same
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
you know i always wondered
why are so many people allergic to nuts
these days i think we should be talking
about that it was unheard of when i was
a kid no it's like everyone seems to
have some kind of nut allergy i don't
understand it we used to let them die
yeah that's what people which is how it
should be really hey look if you can't
eat your peanut you i mean you didn't
make it you know what i mean it was like
you know little jimmy just got really
ill every time you had a peanut butter
sandwich or something yeah
that was fine it was a system that
worked you know what i mean someone had
to come in and mess with it it's
separating the wheat from the chaff
ultimately so i agreed mate
you're not actually allergic to me no
i'm not i just that's a different thing
that's okay yeah you can not like things
yeah right nice to have ended it on a
super right wing note thank you very
much
about saying you deserve to die if you
can't handle it it's just practical
reality you just you're just not keeping
up with the tribe you're slowing
everybody else down yeah but it's been
an absolute pleasure will if people want
to find you online where is the best
place to do that uh you can find me on
youtube under the critical drinker and
you can find me on twitter by the same
handle so fantastic thanks thanks so
much for coming on and thank you for
watching
[Laughter]
this is a question that i would ask you
it's a brilliant question it's from andy
kidd and he wants to know your top five
films and why oh
i always hate these questions actually
well at least there's five so it's not
like um too difficult but uh top five um
one of them would be saving private ryan
just like probably a definitive war
movie for me just absolutely fantastic
um
what else uh i always had a real
fondness for uh falling down that
michael douglas movie the man who i
based my image on yeah
great man i need that flat top hairstyle
yeah um
big trouble in little china just because
it's absolutely peaked john carpenter uh
lovely and cheesy and just really good
fun
so love that one um back to the future
love it um i i could happily watch all
three of them um and just have a great
time but yeah the first one is just
fantastic just real magical movie um and
the last one probably lord of the rings
um the fellowship of the ring i think is
is my favorite again a movie you can
just absolutely lose yourself in so
those would be my picks i think but you
asked me next week it would probably be
different ones yeah yeah it's hard to
pick isn't it yeah uh and uh somebody
called uh i'm sure it's not actually the
home secretary pretty patel but somebody
called pretty patel on our local i'm
pretty sure my immigration papers are in
order yeah you're getting deported back
to scotland yes uh orwanda whichever you
prefer um she says uh why are prequels
and sequels so often disappointing in
comparison to the original
i i think a lot of the time because the
original wasn't written with a sequel in
mind and so what they have to do then is
try and pick up the threads of whatever
story they had and then construct a new
narrative around that so that's why you
sometimes um have a disappointing sequel
and also
a lot of the time you just end up
rehashing the same basic ideas just
bigger and again it's not going to have
that same magic the next time around um
you know the example that i've used
before is is something like predator
yeah one of those like 80s action movies
but it worked great because it was this
mystery about what was killing all these
people you know and how does it work how
can it go invisible all that stuff all
that
all those things have been answered by
the end of the first movie so you try to
do another one all you're doing is just
doing the same thing again but you're
losing the mystery of it
um so i think that's part of the problem
and then prequels
kind of the same
issue in that
you know where it's ultimately going to
end and so if it's if it comes to
characters and so on and they're put in
danger you know they're not going to die
because they're going to be alive in the
next movie so you know you've got a
little bit of a problem there as well um
yeah a lot of the time it's just trying
to construct narratives that weren't
really meant to be there originally uh
that's that's why they're often
disappointed and i suppose it's probably
quite hard to get a studio to agree to
making like a three-part movie unless
there's been a hugely successful book
like the lord of the rings right like
you're not gonna get someone to sign up
to three
three episodes let's say of like a
completely new thing yes yeah makes
sense all right well that's it thank you
very much no problem thank you
[Music]
you